let's do this bitch's whispers in the
dark what the [ __ ] someone up I hide in
a coffin willing to treat me like wet
too disgusting high five
see that section yeah are you sure did
kind of crap what the [ __ ] are we alone
yes we will hear us that's perfect serve
us everything is going according to plan
the others I've spoken to them and
they're coming around I know us to the
wizard is this correct perhaps even the
argonian and the unchosen to anyone you
know I do the talking all the stalking
the seeing Emma saying and what you do
well crazy nothing what not angry oh
never will understand through always
understands
the base she will talk when you're ready
won't you won't you like a night much a
great night mother what job but he will
never hear he is not hello how can I
defend you okay I in search of wins you
will not speak to anyone [ __ ] mikasa
do you owe you Ottawa okay you my iron
was my ancient phone to woman
with a lot
poor little shy on you cause sorry sweet
mother tried so very hard but I just
can't find the time has come counting
the word he's been waiting for all these
years okay what what treachery de pilar
debates her and Defiler you have
violated the sanctity of the night
mother's coffin is [ __ ] crazy speak
warm oh no she she said that she said
those words but those are the words the
binding words written in the taping toes
[Music]
back away for whatever you've been
planning is over are you all right I
heard the commotion who was cicero
talking to where's the accomplice reveal
yourself traitor I spoke only to the
night mother I spoke to the night mother
but she didn't speak to me oh well call
it him
what the listener what are you going on
about what is this lunacy this guy's
crazy mother has spoken well let me look
at that goodie when I have it Cicero
screaming I knew you'd been discovered I
feared the worst are you all right Wow
then what insidious name is going on
what so Cicero wasn't talking and the
night mother to you yeah beber by
sitteth and what did she say am on moti
air I have no idea but Valen rude that I
have heard of hmm no no listen I don't
know what's going on here but you take
your orders from me are we clear on that
the night mother made I I need time to
think about all this track I've ever
seen azir do some work for him I'll find
you when I'm ready to discuss the matter
further okay
this is all just too much too fast go
get some work from the dear
where is there hey that's so many
contracts welding your timing couldn't
be better as it turns out I've got two
new contracts one rather easy assignment
and another that should prove quite to
challenge your first target is an orc
bard namely book the other is a vampire
by the name of Hern happy hunting ok go
on now
here we go yeah thank you